Shh we need to talk about sunscreen so
sunblock and other products with SPF are
one of the best ways we can protect our
skin from UVB rays which are responsible
for sunburns and could cause the type of
damage that may lead to skin cancer but
I don't want you to use just any type of
sunscreen that's because most
conventional sunscreens use certain
chemicals like oxytocin or oxy no sate
to block ultraviolet or UV rays from
your skin when you take a dip in the
ocean apply spray on sunscreen at the
beach or shower off after your fun in
the Sun those chemicals wash off and can
end up in our water systems where they
can harm plant and animal life an
estimated 14,000 tons of sunscreen enter
oceans around the world every year the
chemicals in sunscreen can inhibit
photosynthesis and the growth of green
algae which by some estimates create as
much as thirty to fifty percent of the
oxygen we breathe seems kind of
important fish reproduction and
fertility are affected and fewer eggs
hatch after exposure to these chemicals
the World Wildlife Fund calls seafood
the largest treated food commodity in
the world and about 3.2 billion people
rely on fish as a healthy protein and
chemicals from sunscreen can have a
profoundly negative impact on our coral
reefs by building up the corals tissue
and causing bleaching changes to DNA
deformations and even death a major
study backed by the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration specifically
identified benzathine
also known as oxybenzone or B p3 as a
major hazard to the health of coral but
chemicals aren't the only things that
affect coral reefs climate change
pollution overfishing and invasive
species also threaten these ecosystems
but keep in mind we're losing our coral
reefs at an alarming rate and we need to
do what we can before it's too late
these ecosystems are extremely valuable
and not just environmentally generating
about three hundred and seventy-five
billion dollars annually coral reefs are
a source of food they bring in money for
tourism and they protect our coastlines
from ocean waves without them
we see a lot more property damage and
fatalities due to bad weather chemicals
from sunscreens can even affect dolphins
because it threatens their food supply
consider the fact that the chemicals
from sunscreen also seep into our skin
and the FDA has only recently proposed
that we should be looking into whether
or not these same chemicals that harm
marine life also pose a health risk to
humans but we do need to protect our
skin from the Sun the American Academy
of Dermatology suggests that everybody
over six months old should be using a
sunscreen with SPF 30 or higher but
instead of using sunscreens with harmful
chemicals we can choose mineral based
non nano sunscreens that use zinc oxide
or titanium dioxide and use lotions that
apply it directly onto the skin rather
than a spray
[Music]